how hard was it for you to wear that  muscle suit  first of all let me just say hard was it  I knew you did giving me the business  now this is it that's what I think is so  funny was it hard walking around with  all those muscles Mr Johnson first of  all the first suit that they delivered  to me the first iteration it had muscle  padding so imagine me putting on a suit  with muscle padding my body with muscle  padding I look absurd I mean ridiculous  so I asked them to remove the muscle  padding plus also I was putting in a lot  of work I wanted to transform my body  for the role and we removed it and the  iteration you see on screen  this is no muscle padding yeah so that's  all you so when you look at that do you  go damn I look good because that's what  I said damn you look good what did you  say when you looked at that I said I  said damn you look good I said the same  thing